[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet und in
unserer kleinen süßen minecraft welt und
meine lieben freunde wir haben auf
unsere ich kann ja das habe ich mich
auch gefragt ob das überhaupt noch nie
diese
[Musik]
ja wie soll ich dir helfen du bist auf
dem kopf ich habe gar nichts gemacht
okay das wird bei beiden die kommentare
geschrieben und das ging alles mit
rechten dingen zu wenn ich euch hier
einmal ganz kurz ein
das habe ich mich vor der aufnahme
gerade gemacht das wird mir geschrieben
wenn ich das schwein nämlich dinner
bauen länder dann geht es auf dem kopf
der ganze trick funktioniert noch immer
und jetzt müssen wir das schwein und
wieder hochkriegen hier wurde auf jeden
fall auch unten in die kommentare
ja das wollte ich gerade sagen mir wurde
unter der letzten folge geschrieben dass
sich doch mal mein gerüst ausprobieren
soll von daher laufen wir ganz gut vorne
hin denn die habe ich meine ganze items
und das wollte ich jetzt direkt auch mal
machen das habe ich nämlich noch gar
nicht so richtig ausprobiert ich habe
mir irgendwann mal das gerüst fertig
gemacht hier fordert ist es nämlich und
habe es noch nie so richtig benutzt weil
ich im
ja es war schon echt ein bisschen
komisch in der letzten folge dass ich da
nicht so richtig geschnitten habe das
geld bei an
[Musik]
ach so ich kann einfach einmal drauf
schlagen dann kann ich das aber kann ich
das nicht übereinander setzen
ich setze die ganze zeit nebeneinander
wie was ist denn wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mich jetzt mal hochbahn
will ist noch der gar keinen sinn
ach so ich muss da seitlich und dann
[Musik]
hey
hier spricht die ganze zeit ist auch von
gerüsten welche runter geht meine
minecraft welt ist verhext das gerüst
ist auf jeden fall mégane eis also ich
weiß nicht warum ich das nicht vorher
schon irgendwie ausprobiert habe komme
das geht dann auch alles direkt weg das
ist ja todes teil 1 das werde ich auf
jeden fall für ein paar zukünftige sache
nicht noch bauen wobei die erschreckt
mich jedes mal so oft das werde ich mir
auf jeden fall merken dass ich das bei
meinem nächsten projekt für die
strandvilla beispielsweise mal noch
gebrauchen kann ich muss mal ganz kurz
hier vorne rum und mich hier das glas
mitnehmen und du gehst ganz kurz beck
ich brauche hier unten noch mal eben nee
ich glaube das habe ich das andere glas
schon noch da hinten gepackt weil sie
nicht was ich allerdings auch noch
brauche ist schwarzer farbstoff und
generell schwarzes glas denn ich habe
mir etwas überlegt für die strand hause
will am voi wird fertig allerdings muss
ich heute dafür auch wenn die hölle
gehen und da wurde nämlich auf was in
die kommentare geschrieben was ich noch
nicht gemacht habe und zwar bin ich noch
immer nicht eine sandra geritten also
sondern schreiter mit meiner wir war die
range situation strings booms und das
wollte ich heute mal machen das ist das
ziel so mit sinn für die heutige episode
und dazu noch ein paar kleinere tools
wie beispielsweise dass ich das hier
vorne aus glas machen wollte aus
schwarzem glas ich habe hier schwarzen
farbstoff und ich habe glas das passt
auf jeden fall perfekt habe ich jedoch
irgendwo bruchsteine für den tunnel dann
kann ich da auf jeden fall schon mal
weiter vorgehen und ich werde auch jetzt
schon mal ganz kurz diese öfen abbauen
denn das ist ein bisschen steht die
wirklich alles ein bisschen blut im weg
da muss ich mal gucken dass wir das
irgendwie vernünftig hinkriegen habe ich
noch sagen ständig habe ich nicht ich
frag mal ganz kurz die schwarzen
farbstoff rein und dann bekomme ich hier
wie viele raus 64 recht auf gar keinen
fall ich hole mir nochmal hier so ein
paar ich brauch noch mehr schwarzen
farbstoff allerdings sage ich euch jetzt
mal ganz kurz was mir dabei gedacht habe
jetzt mal ganz kurz das gerüst so ihr
seht unten im inventar bereits dass sich
einerseits das gerüst geholt habe
allerdings auch noch eine menge
bruchsteinen denn das können jetzt
gleich für unseren tunnel auch mal ein
bisschen benutzen da müssen wir auch ein
bischen vorankommen von drei sätze als
mach ich sehe schon wieder falsch sagt
ihr alle weg und hier kann ich jetzt
nicht so entspannt hier einfach die
taste gedrückt halten komme hier hoch
und das hier bleibt bestehen allerdings
werde ich nun hier vorne diese blöcke
abbauen so dass wir hier von nur noch
zwei hier an der seite übrig haben
das ganze werde ich jetzt hier einmal so
umziehen und ich werde hier an der seite
jetzt die quarzwerke die hier bekommen
habe nehmen und das ganze ich hier so
wieder hinsetzen so dass ich dann hier
zwischen quasi schwarzes glas packen
kann
[Musik]
so soll das ganze dann hier auf jeden
fall aussehen hiervon habe ich noch ein
glas vergessen beziehungsweise gehe ich
glaube ich erst mal hier ganz kurzem ein
gerüst runter dann kann ich das hier
nämlich direkt wieder mitnehmen exakt
und setzte hier dann ganz kurz den
letzten glas block hin
dann seht ihr das wie ich mir das hier
ganz kurz hier vorgestellt habe also
normalerweise wird hier alles komplett
aus glas aus quarz gemacht hier fahre
ich noch eine reihe vergessen ist mir
aufgefallen allerdings habe ich mir dann
in meiner test welt gedacht mensch sieht
irgendwie bisschen schöner aus wenn ihr
schwarzes glas ist einerseits nicht der
himmel dadurch noch ein bisschen geiler
aus und wir haben noch ein bisschen
lichteinfall hier können dadurch gucken
und haben wir dann hier unten unseren
sandbelag das soll hier vorne auch noch
mal hin dass wenn ich gleich machen
allerdings muss ich jetzt erst mal kurz
zurück laufen das ganze glas bzw
schwarze glas nehme ich jetzt auch
erstmal mit ich musste mich auf jeden
fall erstmal ganz gut schlafen gehen ich
habe nämlich heute keine lust auf stress
mit irgendwelchen monstern
denn das darf ich mir auch nicht antun
ich hab nämlich mal wieder eine blöde
situation die mir passiert das kann ich
euch ganz kurz erzählen aber die mir bei
instagram folgen play valluga habt ihr
auch die tage ein cooles foto aus paris
hoch gelernt könnt ihr euch gerne folgen
haben das ja schon bei einer story
gesehen ich find das echt so komisch
dass das schwein ist einfach mit ja aber
wie soll ich's dann rückgängig machen
wir in einer der nächsten folgen dann
können wir das schweinchen auf jeden
fall habe ich in afrika gesehen
lena ja da kann mir das schweinchen auf
jeden fall wieder papa nennen wir
überhaupt mal papa nennen
ja ich war am wochenende unterwegs oder
schanze in hamburg leicht angetrunken
und bin leider hingefallen war zunächst
von einem kollegen und ich meinte sogar
kommen das überfahren kickflip und der
war irgendwie getunt und auf einmal ich
meinen bogen dabei
weg mit dir weg mit dir so mein gott wie
können denn hier alle direkt in das pony
von skelett weg weg so apropos skelett
übrigens da wurde mir auch ohne die
kommentare geschrieben luca muss
unbedingt wieder in eine skelett farben
geben die wir ja dort hinten haben
deswegen werde ich mich da jetzt erst
mal kurz hinstellen und euch denn die
story so ein bisschen erzählen also hier
vorne haben wir unseren skeletts borner
da sehen wir auch schon das gerade glaub
ich was gesponnen das jahr da vorne ist
es ergeht hier vornherein wird jetzt
hier hochgeschleudert fällt hier wieder
runter klappt das alles noch ich weiß es
gar nicht war ja schon lange nicht mehr
drin sein papa
da war das gerät auf jeden fall und
jetzt halt so viel schaden bekommen dass
ich hier einfach einmal gut schlagen
kann und dann bekomme ich ein paar level
denn das wird mir halt geschrieben habe
ich wird nicht gerade geschrieben aber
ich hab's euch gerade schon vorgelesen
das wenn ich dann einfach hier warte ich
ein paar erfahrungspunkte bekomme und
ich damit dann hoffentlich eine
spitzhacke vernünftig verzaubern kann
denn wir werden heute auch noch in die
hölle gehen ich euch auch schon gesagt
und zwar richtig sondern sandra ging
reiten und dann kann ich dort das ganze
mal testen und kann dazu auch noch ein
bisschen quarz rahmen für unsere
strandhaus villa allerdings bevor wir
hier jetzt wirklich die ganze zeit nur
dumm rumstehen waren und ich euch eine
temmels einwände kann ich euch ja ganz
kurz mal die sache erzählen mit dem
wochenende
und zwar ganz kurz sie wieder story teil
wie gesagt bin ich auf dem e scooter der
an einem kollegen gehört hat bin ich
betrunken gefahren und leicht
angetrunken schon bin leider motiv hat
genommen von dem auto und ich bin
ausgewichen
also dass ich halt nicht in das auto
rein fahren und bin dabei hingefallen
und mit meiner ganzen linken seite hat
auf dem boden ich hab jetzt hier überall
irgendwelche runden hier das sieht jetzt
gar nicht so schlimm ausweis komplett
eingeklemmt habe ich habe auch hier an
meinem knie auch eine fette wunde und
das schlimmste was ich habe das habt ihr
wahrscheinlich schon mit der story
gesehen das kann ich euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal zeige ich
zeig mal auf entfernung
ich habe eine platzwunde und beim
richtigen caps also das ging mir ein
zentimeter tief ich hätte ins
krankenhaus fahren müssen aber natürlich
nicht gemacht so wie wir sind
dann habe ich ein paar fehler nicht
einfach mit die dauert hier das ein
bisschen wie hast du das letzte mal
gemacht da waren halt voll viele weiche
ein fachforum stand ich muss mich
eigentlich mal am ende der folge hier
wieder hinstellen dann mache ich zu
beginn der nächsten folge direkt dass
sich halt warten bis hier ganz viele
skelette kommen und dann machen wir das
würde ich sagen dann kriegt das heute
leider nicht mit der kompletten
verzauberung von einer spitzhacke
allerdings hab ich ja noch die glück
eine spitzhacke und ich kann versuchen
eine eisen spitzhacke noch zu verzaubern
mit glück vielleicht kriegen wir daher
ganz gute angebot hat das müssen wir auf
jeden fall gleich mal gucken jetzt will
ich allerdings sagen meine lieben
freunde bereite ich mich erstmal ganz
kurz vor auf die hölle beziehungsweise
fällt mir gerade auf dass ich vielleicht
ja auch mal eben kurz meine ganzen
schweine hier nehmen kann und den tunnel
hier ein bisschen weiter bauen kann also
euch da jetzt erst mal eine ganz kurze
teil bleibt
so die sonne geht da hinten schon wieder
unter allerdings habe ich hier schon ein
kleines stückchen mehr von unserem
unterwasser tunnel geschafft zeigt euch
mal ganz kurz ja auch von unterwasser
dann seht ihr das vielleicht ein
bisschen besser wenn ich mal kurz den
lang schwimmen also hier an der seite so
dass ganze zeit lang gehen und wenn man
dadurch schwimmt die 26 den ganzen
korallenriffe da muss ja auf jeden fall
noch ein paar mehr meeresboden hin
platzieren sodass das hier unter wasser
noch mal alles ein bisschen schöner
beleuchtet ist allerdings gehe ich jetzt
mal ganz gut schlafen und muss euch dann
tatsächlich direkt die nächste times
einen blenden wie ich mich ganz kurz auf
die netter vorbereitet so ich bin
vorbereitet für die hölle meine lieben
freunde und ihr seht doch schon in einem
inventar eingeblendet ich habe mich auf
jeden fall wirklich gut vorbereitet
diesmal haben ist sogar ein flinten stil
mitbekommen mitgenommen als ein
feuerzeug so dass ich wenn ich mich
verlaufen sollte zumindest irgendwo oder
das portal ausgehen sollte dass ich ein
neues portal werden wir dort machen kann
mit dem portal neue anzünden kann hier
vorne ich habe mir auch holz mitgenommen
eisenwaren alles mögliche was ich
benötige oder kompass der macht auf
jeden fall party in dir vorne ist ja
unser portal und ich weiß dass wir auf
jeden fall in die richtung schon krass
wie gegangen sind bezüglich gefahr nach
hier vorn und nach da wo wir allerdings
noch gar nicht hingegangen sind und
jetzt winkt ihr euch wahrscheinlich herr
luca wir sind auch schon gelaufen da ist
auf unsere festung und 2000 sofort ja
ein
die sache ist allerdings dass ich da nie
nach hier oben gegangen bin und da haben
wir auch direkt watt also euch jetzt geh
ich bin so ein idiot ich habe diese vier
warzen angel vergessen die wir für
diesen sandra schreit allerdings
brauchen
bereits im inventar eingeblendet ich
habe hier kurz meine wie pilze geholt
und mir noch einen sattel den ich glaube
ich auch dafür benötige weil es nicht
mehr ganz genau allerdings euch jetzt
erstmal bis ich so eine sandra finde
eine ganz kurze tablets wie schwarz
pharma
[Musik]
alles easy bruder trendig aus danke ich
sage ganz kurze time labs und dies
direkt lava oder was auf der höhe
jetzt eine ganz kurze time labs es gibt
für mich ausdenken schon wieder lava
[Musik]
jetzt dann auch wirklich die time lab
sah ich dann wirklich 37 minuten in der
hölle quartz farben war habe ich mir
gedacht mensch
ihr habt sag ich mal wieder verdient
hier euch einen wunderbar geilen ich
habe ganz neuen jetzt wirklich gut und
zwar es sehe ich persönlich ja nicht
jede sorte chips denn ich bin der
wehrpflicht wegen prügel- pingping
pingelig und also es ist nicht nicht
gesponsert von von pringles nicht dass
jetzt in wer denkt dass ich jetzt im wie
geld oder also wie findet ihr denn wird
so ungelogen 5 37 minuten später sehen
wir uns jetzt hier wieder im netz
meine lieben frau die sich schon ich
habe 37 level das ist wirklich
geisteskrank dahin
da ist ein portal was ich letztes gebaut
habe es hier gar nicht so weit
naja was ich auf jeden fall sagen wollte
meine lieben freunde war dass ich eins
zwei einhalb stacks quad habe das hätte
jetzt nicht zuviel an allerdings habe
ich auch noch meine glück ein spitzhacke
und habe wirklich eigentlich heißt es
kann viel abgebaut die sache ist jetzt
allerdings dass ich jetzt gerade mal die
tablets beendet habe da hier unten
diese
kleinen sandras rumlaufen allerdings
kommen die nicht zu mir
also ich würde eigentlich gerne auf den
reiten
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie ich an dir
ankommen soll hier vorne ist auf jeden
fall einer freundin habe ich hier gerade
entdeckt dass sie direkt nehmen
wenn ich jetzt hier raus ich bin einfach
zu beraten ich kann einfach über die
lahn arbeiten
das ist ja der komplette game changer
wie geht das
krank okay das heißt ich kann er
theoretisch einfach hier vorne zum
quatschen reiten und diese so langsam
gezittert nachdem muss wahrscheinlich in
die lava rein damit ihm nicht kalt ist
oder dann kann ich hier einmal ganz kurz
absteigen er bleibt hiervon du kannst
auch ruhig zurück gehen hier vorne hin
ich brauche mal ganz kurz jetzt noch mal
ein bisschen im quarz ab und reiter
wissen über die lage des todes neues
zehn sekunden später natürlich bruder da
haben wir die sandra wieder zurück so
einmal schnell aufgestiegen ich habe
mich hier vorne jetzt gerade ein
bisschen vorgebaut bin dabei auch wieder
halb gestorben
ihr seht auch schon unten das sind sogar
die lieben glaube ich von der sandra
dann gerade oder also sieht auf jeden
fall ein bisschen komisch aus ich weiß
jetzt auch grad gar nicht doch hier
vorne ist auf jeden fall mein portal da
kommen wir dann hier unten irgendwo hoch
beziehungsweise kann mich dann auch
einfach hier vorne raus lassen ich weiß
nicht ob sie hier hochkommt
das kriegt sie nicht hin da brauche ich
mir immer ganz kurz eine konstruktion
hier zeigt dann können wir an der seite
hoch laufen allerdings meine lieben
freunde haben wir heute wieder eine
menge geschafft ich bin der aufnahme bei
mehr als eineinhalb stunden wir kommen
nach hauses ist natürlich
selbstverständlich wieder nacht
beziehungsweise geht die nacht gerade
los ok schade ich dachte die sonne geht
da hinten gerade auf man eigentlich noch
mal ganz kurz eben schlafen das problem
ist dass ich jetzt eigentlich noch den
quartz verbauen wollte an der strandhaus
würde allerdings packe ich das nicht
mehr weil ich jetzt noch ein termin habe
auch der termin war vor 13 minuten sind
wir jedoch zu spät
er wollte eigentlich niemals mit mir
irgendwie geschäfte machen das geht nie
klar geschäfte machen hört sich auf eine
total suspekt ansatz immer so ein
bisschen illegal an
na ja ich hatte auf jeden fall ein
termin in der innenstadt allerdings
musste weiter um 16.30 deswegen ist
jetzt auch egal also ich brauche auf
jeden fall
sechs blöcke das heißt dafür muss ich
dann doch nochmal meine öfen aufbauen
beziehungsweise kann die häfen von hier
vornehmen
und da ich jetzt hier warten muss bis
die ganzen sachen fertig gebraten sind
hier vorne mal ich noch welche rein und
da nehme ich gern mal die hälfte raus
dann kann ich es ein bisschen besser
verteilen da ich eh warten muss bis die
ganzen sachen fertigt sind würde ich das
video dann an der stelle jetzt doch
beenden meine lieben freunde deswegen
kennst ja bereits wenn solch gefallen
hat dann das kann einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da ab und man kann
einen klick auf die glocke wenn ihr neue
videos von dem projekt minecraft mit
luca nicht verpassen wollt hier vorne
noch kohle rein und hier oder seien die
fakten nicht nur damit ich sehe mir noch
mal ganz schnell neben ein brötchen
werde jetzt auch auf spielen schnell
noch warten dass das hier fertig geht
ich werde meine items sortieren und dann
werde ich mich hinten in die
skelettteile stellen das werde ich euch
jetzt allerdings nicht mehr einblenden
von daher würde ich euch an der steller
das heutige video jetzt schon mal
beenden liebe freunde wir sehen uns
übermorgen wieder um 20 uhr und ihr
könnt mir jetzt gern mal wieder uns in
die kommentare schreiben was sich in
diesen neuen video machen soll außer
dann halt den quartz verbauen
[Musik]